[Musique]
militer auprès de la vie si tous qu'on
est astucieux telle peine est la seule
issue est le plus sérieux
[Musique]
il dit vouloir revenir à un ami
bonjour fabrice elle hello hello hello
i'm are you might as well you my dear
friend iam very well that good smile et
didon j'arrive on se souciait à quoi je
pense non à tous ses petits enfants qui
dessine si bien tu sais ce que me disait
petit ou non non qu'est ce que tu disais
qui tous et j'ai rien dit du tout pour
que tu puisses ya deux choses que je
pense que oui
alors qu'est ce que c'est que ça mettez
vous d'accord bon allez bon c'est une
querelle de famille je me rends compte
pas lancer qu elle n'entrons pas dans ce
cas quelles expériences réalisées très
difficile on est large et je vois mieux
des jeunes et de préparer nous non mais
je vous demandais alors d'être très
attentifs et je te demande et où quand
et titou de ne pas faire de bruit parce
que vraiment là c'est très délicat
on peut circuler non ce n'est pas la
peine mais voyez déjà au départ une
bouteille de vin normale et vous avez
ici un bouchon sur ce bouchon nous avons
planté là une aiguille sale pétrin
faites attention parce que c'est délicat
car il ya une aiguille nous allons
essayer de faire tenir cette assiette
sur cette aiguille en équilibrant avec
des fourchettes et des bouchons que nous
avons planté dans la fourchette
regardez la fourchette et le bouchon
vous voyez comment c'est fait voilà
c'est appétissant
c'est extrêmement tapé dix ans mais ça
n'est pas fait pour ça ça je vais
maintenant m'être les fourchettes en
équilibre sur la sienne est extrêmement
difficile
c'est un exercice périlleux il ya eu des
accidents faut se méfier
puis je vous demanderais lorsque vous le
ferez de prendre toutes vos précautions
au cinéma des maisons j'ai vu un film où
il y avait ça c'est vrai oui c'est
seulement les fourchettes elle été
remplacés par des actrices à bon rythme
cela va être délicat comme situation
alors voyez vous nous allons essayer
maintenant le plus délicat placé en
équilibre sur l'aiguillé
bien sûr que c'est ensemble que toi ça
c'est difficile c'est extrêmement
délicat je crois je crois mesdames
messieurs que c'est c'est réussi ne
bougeait plus ni titou ni donc encore
car nous allons maintenant le faire
tourner ce manège étonnant on souffre
légèrement haussé très olalalala didon
c'est d'une rare beauté assez d'une
heure à reboiser d'une rare beauté et
sur une aiguille
voilà mesdames messieurs l'or là je
crois vraiment besoin alors là fabrice
je suis obligé de m'incliner bien bas je
m'incline incline touati tous ses biens
ah bon et ben nous allons faire le mot à
mot rom de mode
tu crois que cela devrait s'arrêter là
moi j'arrêterai ici oui m'enfin ce ne
serait pas raisonnable
bah allez on va faire le matin même
c'est bien enfin préparer les ont
soutenus boussu et beh oui on va faire
l'amour quand même absolument
d'autant plus que le mot à mot vous le
connaissez bien maintenant vous regardez
des cartons avec des dessins ce sont des
syllabes
si vous préférez d aider des morceaux de
mots et à partir des ses syllabes de ses
morceaux nous réformons d'autres mots et
ils sont en général très très fort mais
je suis sûr que vous aussi vous savez
très bien les jouer alors nous prenons
cinq cartes comme d'habitude ça va mais
louis ah oui ça va me suis sûr
qu'aujourd'hui je serai un petit peu
plus doué que la dernière fois darwin
mais faut le temps de s'habituer à ces
normes à la bien belle à l'heure je
prends cinq cartes alors premier quart
tôt c'est quoi c'est un c'est un carton
non mais quoi alors oui en tout cas
quand c'est pas un verre inverse bon
mais le bel qu'est ce que bell non c'est
pas belles belles success est belle tout
court qu'est ce que c'est ça
ou alors c'était mais cette quête et
paquet bien attaquer et à marennes belle
belle aime beaucoup ce qu'est d'ailleurs
et oui puisqu'elle est partie
ben oui elle adore les voyages justement
elle m'a donné de ses nouvelles et puis
elle m'a dit qu'elle pensait beaucoup à
beaucoup c'est gentil gentil tulle
embrassera pour nous tu lui écrire à
tous quand c'est quoi ça ça c'est une
scène bon et ça ça c'est la pique
oui et ça c'est quoi ça c'est court dont
c'était un coup oui mais oui j'étais un
gros sac roussarie cros oui oui et ça
c'est quoi ça c'est un bain c'est une
connerie c'est un vrai bon vie alors
maintenant faut chercher des dons or
alors moi je trouvais que couche ou very
douce à trouver crocs et crocs quand
nago au creux après look et brooke est à
croquer ah oui je ne comptais le croquer
au lido alors comment est perçu le
croquer je t'écoute a annoncé en or et
war and hommage au sport alors voici
tout con quand à la croquer sirou cul
oui 1 oui après lieu tongs et comment tu
le ticket non pas que tu veux que tu
pues eh ben j'ai le croquant et porsche
pas des noises tout le temps alors tu
ajoutes très amusant wheeler autre plus
fort que moi pour l'orthographe c'est
vraiment la meilleure en orthographe ici
c'est moi c'est vrai mais pourquoi oui
bah ma marraine ou si c'était la
meilleure main elles appellent cherchent
à nous humilier un missile américain
mais non mais non à l'arrêt sur l
arrière sel on va pas faire grand chose
là bas non et je mords il faut alors va
pour les chrétiens le carton ça c'est
quoi ça on doit s'assigner
avait on dirait du coup c'est du goût
enfin ceci c'est quoi gagner mais c'est
l'heure ce qui compte ce soit celle ans
lance du panier assez lisse à l'homme
d'ailleurs il est beaucoup plus marbry
oui c'est long alors là j'ai trouvé là
dedans sera trouvée retrouver we not and
ivory hombourg peut faire on peut faire
quoi tu sens le vert un sens le vert je
sens le vert mendy le goût et le loup ça
fait vers vous avez vous alors 1 avec
deux r voiliers et oui voilà
félicitations à alors là et nous allons
et non regardez mais une des lettres
qu'on nous a envoyé des lettres
absolument superbe
il ya des dessins sublimes vous y voir
alors celle ci nous avons marqué vient
d'eux
alors écoutez c'est stéphane fievet qui
habite reims et qui est un réel talent
regardez déjà nous avons belles belles
pousses moussu toucan rapidos et moi
même
oui on est toujours à regarder ça ah oui
on est au gabon regardez comme on les
barrages sur les biens les beaux seins
on est très bien comme ça on est même
avantagé oui oui et alors là il a fait
un autre dessin c'est nous mais dans la
forêt dans nos activités diverses enfin
c'est déjà plus c'est déjà plus
compliqué c
oui c'est fin d'activité et oui c'est
une sorte de fresque au même homme
c'est bien alors je propose que nous
envoyons à stéphane le disque des quatre
amis vous êtes d'accord
oh oui oh moi j'ai une affaire l'inde
est d'accord nous sommes d'accord très
bien et bien maintenant c'est à nous
fabriquer pas alors nous y alors
allons-y
allons-y et bien cette semaine ça va
être difficile je ne sais pas si tu vas
trouver la banque était fort mais là
c'est un peu difficile on commence par
quoi
eh bien d'abord c'est à mon en neuf
lettres 9 pouces et beaucoup ça neuf
lettres au nom de fletch et normal alors
commence par un p ah tiens donc voilà
oui alors tu fais tes petits traits fins
qu 2 3 4 5 6 7 et las vergnas net t1 une
voie là haut tu vois alors j'ai alors
dit moi cette saison c'est de la viande
oeufs à oui oui oui c'est de la viande
il ya pas que de la vie en a pas c'est
de la viande avec des légumes alors à
bari et la viande avec des légumes c'est
un c'est un plat très d'un zèbre en
france et oui oui très appréciée surtout
surtout l'hiver je te donne une petite
nature
alors là la troisième l'est prix c'est
un thé au oui la troisième set 1-6 à des
légumes ont dit oui alors tu me dises
temps neuf lettres et ça va pas ça
ces composés il ya plusieurs maux de dos
oui oui tu veux te même pas me dire que
tu nous suggère l'idée du pot-au-feu de
pot-au-feu babya alors là j'aimerais
savoir et alors tout quand tu vas
t'amuser tient ni écoute comment il est
temps qu est ce que tu veux voir écoute
comment il épelle pot-au-feu vésenaz ge
est simple oui p o t attends attends
attends tu me paies au après hot et
terry fleurs à une f e us pot-au-feu
peau
malheureux commençons vont aller où
enfin pour geof le genevois la faute aux
et feu tu fais des fautes innovantes et
lala lala bond au feu ah bon bon bon bon
ben laden moi j'avais écrit pot-au-feu
parce que dans le pot-au-feu ya toujours
un os énorme a reconnu un poteau un
poteau mapoto bah oui alors j'ai écrit
pot-au-feu comme un poteau en plus je
viens d'apprendre quelque chose ça
s'écrit en trois mots ça je ne le savais
pas parce que tu écrivais san nas à
banias seulement pas pot-au-feu pas prêt
à ça enfin là j'essaierai de faire mieux
la prochaine fois
en attendant allons voir belle un bon ok
3 fabrice vial jouer avec moi là c'est
facile
la visite du beffroi bien mon petit
favori oui belge ischios steam tu es
d'accord pour m'accorder quelques
instants d'attention absolument est bien
bien bien je vais te fournir l'occasion
de nous prouver tes talents de musicien
alors battu faisait pas toujours facile
là on va essayer mais bon alors je vais
te demander de reconnaître l'instrument
que je vais te faire écouter alors
appuyé sur le bouton moi j'écoute
j'appuie sur le bouton ah oui
[Musique]
[Rires]
jolie bombe ces mots elle belle sonorité
[Applaudissements]
agissez pour en arriver là faut être
fort aussi parce que tu as remarqué avec
quelle rapidité l'instrumentiste joue
hausse est une flûte traversière ça on
s'en sert comme ça d'ailleurs dans notre
magasin à musique que nous avons pour
nous nous avons tout un tas
d'instruments
je vais chercher une flûte que si je
jouais de la fête non t'es pas en jouer
mais je vais la montrer
on joue et je ne sais pas quoi c'est
très difficile très difficile à guérir
ou la radio c'est difficile parce que
c'est j'ai essayé de souffler dedans
déjà une fois et je n'ai pas réussi à
sortir grand chose
je vais essayer encore une fois pour
vous mais je ne garantis rien c'est
bizarre
et vous c'est pas fait pas fameux voilà
j'arrête deux actes parce que hein ça
fatigue et 2 j'avais pas mais
l'instrument en lui-même est très beau
c'est un bel instrument de musique
mais il faut arriver à bien placer ses
lèvres pour autant une jolie sonorités
souffler pas trop fort mais juste où il
faut ça nous demanda au moins une demi
heure avant que je sorte un son correct
on n'a pas de temps à perdre
alors on met ses mains comme ça en gros
un jeu ne se joue pas la fuite j'ai
l'impression qu'ils mettent leurs miles
à il souffle là et plus alors ils font
les notes en appuyant sur les
différentes clés voilà pourquoi elle
commença doit finalement une fleuriste
un tuyau avec des petits trous pour
aider leurs favoris si tu veux
énormément dessous il faut surtout
savoir le fait je suis dit c'est pas
grave encore une dernière fois et est
rapidement allé c'est un peu mieux
c'est un peu moche en oeuvre
[Musique]
les 4 samedi
c'est déjà papa les amis des quatre
classes de la vie majeur s'est désisté
et g shock et des chaussons les comme
juni pas de baignoire
nigro à faire attention les qualifs à
guy sont pas des sorties médiatiques ça
me saoule heureux car il est valable
ça a joué aujourd'hui et je vis à vis de
vouloir devenir amis
il a dit non là c'est alors
[Musique]